ciao ragazzi allora faccio questo video
per informarvi diciamo di tutto ciò che
sta succedendo su youtube
nell'ultimo mese mettiamola così ve lo
dico perché in realtà non so se molti di
voi l'hanno notato noi youtuber tutti i
dominata vorrei tirare testate al muro
di continuo però vabbè youtube
nell'ultimo mese sta avendo problemi ma
problemi enormi cioè non ha mai avuto un
problema così cioè rispetto
il problema più grande da 1 a 10 finora
era stato sei ok e semini mi riferisco
ad apocalypse
ecco questo problema è da 10 e orribile
vi spiego stesso stanno succedendo delle
cose che vanno stanno lentamente proprio
distruggendo youtube stesso cioè youtube
sta proprio morendo io spero con tutto
il cuore che questa cosa si risolva
perché è un problema veramente grosso
andiamo subito al punto vi spiego cosa
sta succedendo non so se l'avete notato
ma nell'ultimo mese le visualizzazioni
mie e di un sacco di altri youtubers
sono tipo calate del 30 40 per cento
rispetto al solito c'è i miei video ad
esempio quando si pubblicano dopo 24 ore
totalizzano circa 200.000 views più o
meno che sono sono tante però rispetto a
quante ne faccio io di solito sono
pochissime sono veramente poche un video
se andava così così circa un mese fa
faceva 300 350 mila visualizzazioni dopo
24 ore adesso ne fa 200 alle volte
neanche ci arriva all'inizio io pensavo
fosse un problema mio
cioè pensavo di la gente sto periodo
magari sono iniziate le scuole non
studiare tutti magari un periodo in cui
faccio cose molto simili quindi magari
devo cambiare un po quindi pensavo fosse
un mio problema e
lamela vivevo molto tranquillamente nel
senso che succede ma magari cambia un po
il format invece ho scoperto pian piano
parlando con tutti i miei colleghi che
questa cosa non è non è un problema mio
perché ce l'hanno tutti ma tutti quanti
ed è un problema di youtube è saltato
fuori che un problema di youtube e non è
un problema piccolo da quando ho
iniziato questo bug perché è iniziato
allora circa il 6 ottobre non mi ricordo
bene
lo spiega bene mark player vi lascio
subito in descrizione comunque circa il
6 ottobre
youtube è andato giù per tipo 2 ore cioè
non potevi entrare su youtube per due
ore youtube non funzionava youtube
credo per quanto riguarda gli scandali
di facebook che sono usciti ultimamente
va bene non so se riguarda esattamente
quello però youtube ha buttato giù cioè
sta cercando di buttare giu google plus
che cos'è google plus plus e la
piattaforma molto simile a facebook che
rende youtube un po più social che si è
integrata con youtube negli ultimi anni
che non usava nessuno per prove youtube
quindi attende sta tentando ancora
adesso di buttarla giù perché un
processo che richiede tantissimo tempo
visto che google plus è integrata dentro
youtube e nel fare questo stanno
solamente restare si sta cancellando
stanno creando un milione di problemi
che fanno fatica a risolvere mentre
google plus si sta togliendo da youtube
youtube sta soffrendo di questi bug
allucinanti ci abbiamo perso il 30 40
per cento delle pisa video e non riesce
a risolversi questo problema addirittura
noi abbiamo delle pagine su youtube che
che servono per analizzare insomma i
nostri video
alcune di queste schede se le cleac'h e
adesso non funzionano neanche più cioè
non funzionano dei pezzi di youtube non
funzionano durante i live streaming gli
spettatori sono la metà della metà di
quelli che dovrebbero essere perché un
po non vengono segnalati un po non li
conta un po non arrivano le notifiche è
un problema gigante ma veramente
gigantesco youtube sta quindi andando
giù di views tutti quanti si stanno
lamentando e tutti quanti
la cosa peggiore che tutti quanti
pensavano fosse un problema loro c'è
tutti tipo
non so anche i mezzi sono arrivati da me
e mi ha detto è ma le divise sono basse
ragazzi non è colpa vostra youtube che
sta avendo dei problemi perché poi tutti
siccome non ci sono state segnalazioni
da parte di youtube è questo il problema
temi non ha proprio dichiarato questa
cosa e lo abbiamo capito tutti insieme
parlando tra di noi youtuber italiani
stranieri cioè lui l'unico che ho visto
esporre veramente il problema faccia a
faccia con youtube uno youtube le norme
da venti e passa milioni di iscritti che
mark lei a quello che ho detto prima che
vi lascio in descrizione il video con
loro questo che sto facendo io solo in
inglese
è un problema che abbiamo scoperto
parlando tra di noi ipotizzato che il
problema potesse essere questo di google
plus ed è ovvio che quello lì il fatto è
che youtube non dichiarando questa cosa
qui ha fatto fa credere un po hippy e
tor che sia colpa loro anche se non è
così quindi io fossi dichiarerei questa
cosa qua perché molti si stanno
demoralizzando mettiamola così quando i
contenuti non vanno proprio bene
continuano andare bene anche se tu cambi
in pole format eccetera
uno si demoralizza anche quindi se siete
youtubers state guardando questo video e
avete notato questo calo nell'ultimo
mese tranquilli che purtroppo è
normalissimo perché faccio questo video
perché vabbè io comunque vivo di youtube
c'è per me you tube il mio lavoro con
questo calo io riesco comunque a vivere
di youtube però ci sono persone che
vivono su youtube che guadagna uno
stipendio che gli permette a malapena di
sopravvivere e questo prima del bug
adesso che c'è stato questo bug io non
immagino in che condizioni si possono
trovare certe persone quindi se siete
youtubers sete in questa situazione qua
tranquilli che tranquilli una sega però
tranquilli perché ce l'abbiamo tutti non
è un problema vostro che speriamo che
questa cosa si risolva nel tempo anche
se ormai è passato già un mese e non è
cambiato niente anzi stanno un po
peggiorando le cose io ci tenevo a
condividerlo con voi perché magari anche
voi avete notato che i vostri youtube
preferiti io stesso siamo calati di
virus non è per colpa nostra ma è
proprio youtube che non manda le
notifiche e ha dei problemi interni
da circa un mese è un problema gigante
gigantesco però che ci possiamo fare
niente quindi andare avanti speriamo si
risolva e io sono qua nel caso
avete domande o roba iscrivete qua sotto
e proprio vedere se riesco a rispondervi
robe del genere tanto comunque è un
problema nostro
abo in me frega nulla io comunque a
prescindere dalle views fare video mi
diverto quindi continuare a comunque non
è che me ne frega nulla però quando
youtube diventa il vostro lavoro avere
questi problemi
diventa pesante c'è uno cerca di non
farlo vedere ma è veramente pesante cioè
io è da un mese che giorno e notte non
ci dormo per sta roba
sì adesso sto esagerando però insomma è
un problema vero ci confrontiamo di
continuo noi siamo tutti preoccupati voi
non lo vedete non lo sapete ma è così
credete quindi ragazzi questo è tutto
speriamo che google plus vada giù il
prima possibile che youtube risolvere i
problemi che si sono creati sperando che
ci riesca perché non è neanche detto e
ci aveva passato tanti momenti difficili
da quando da fondo esploso mettiamola
così quindi spero passerà anche questo
poi non preoccupatevi che comunque noi
cerchiamo sempre di portarvi il miglior
contenuto possibile a discapito proprio
delle chiuse quindi tranquilli spero vi
sia piaciuto ragazzi come al solito
momento e mi piace anche ai vari social
comunista descrizione se non solo
prestiti iscrivetevi e noi ci vediamo
l'anno prossimo video da ragazzi